einen kleinen moment ich hoffe es wir
haben kontakt ich hoffe liebe zuschauer
dass sie nicht verstehen können jetzt so
ich bin das ist um das thema des tages
natürlich auch bei uns geht es geht um
den zumindest teilweise von astrazeneca
zumindest unter 60 jahren
[Musik]
derzeit mit den ministerpräsidenten über
das weitere vorgehen und wir warten auf
die kanzlerin die danach die ergebnisse
dieser runde verkünden will wir wollen
die zeit aber gerne nutzen um davor
schon zu sprechen mit karl lauterbach
dem gesundheitsexperten der spd der uns
zugeschaltet ist aus berlin schönen
guten abend herr lauterbach schön dass
sie sich wieder die zeit für uns nehmen
herr professor lauterbach widersteht
astrazeneca in der kritik es ist gerade
mal rund zwei wochen her
das ist ja schon mal eine erzwungene
pause gab nun also wieder dieser stopp
was ist das für ein rückschlag für die
impfkampagne in deutschland es ist
zunächst einmal ein vertrauensverlust
für den impfstoff sei jetzt aber ich
glaube dass die kampagne selbst wieder
fahrt aufnehmen wird
wir haben in den letzten tagen
zusätzliche - vielen thrombosen bei
jüngeren die zusammenarbeit jungen
frauen gesehen
es ist wie damals das so auch schon als
erwartet wurde ein hochspezifischer
nebenwirkungen des impfstoffs selbst und
also sie betrifft einen mechanismus den
man mittlerweile auch gedacht ich gut
kennt also da doch tatsächlich die
universitäts kreisrat hier in
deutschland sogar noch einen
wesentlichen beitrag zu lassen können
aber auch einfach andere spezialisten
und somit auch so haben wir es mit einer
nebenwirkung zu tun die bei jüngeren
menschen dann doch etwas häufiger als
gedacht wir haben zuerst gedacht es
kommt alle 250.000
jetzt sehen wir dass es eher so in der
größenordnung ist das ist auch so eine
komplikation 400.000 vielleicht auch
etwas dafür genutzt das vorkommt und das
bedeutet dass man in dem stoff besser
einsetzt für diejenigen und die
komplikationen selbst wenn ich bei den
älteren über 60 irgendwo der nutzen der
irgendwann größer ist weil das coebad
todesrisiko ist bei den 80 jährigen 600
mal so hoch wie bei den 30-jährigen
jetzt haben sie schon einige zahlen
genannt wir wollen uns gerade noch mal
von meinem kollegen an seinem stern auf
den aktuellen stand der dinge bringen
lassen was diesen impfstoff astrazeneca
angeht und was eben auch heute die
entwicklungen
tages waren sein beitrag schon wieder
schlechte nachrichten schon wieder wegen
astrazeneca menschen unter 60 soll
dieser impfstoff nicht mehr gespritzt
werden entscheidet heute schon am frühen
nachmittag zum beispiel das land berlin
betroffen etwa kliniken wie die charité
oder auch große impfzentren in tegel und
tempelhof werden die termine von unter
60 jährigen erst mal abgesagt
und dann wollen wir erstmal abwarten was
die empfehlung ist die empfehlung kommt
dann von der ständigen impfkommission
astrazeneca jetzt nur noch für über
60-jährige grund wohl auch diese zahlen
bis heute nachmittag wurden 31 fälle von
sogenannten sinus venenthrombosen nach
der impfung gemeldet in neun fällen mit
tödlichem ausgang betroffen insgesamt
zwei männer und 29 frauen im alter
zwischen 20 und 63
wir haben festgestellt dass wir eine
häufung habe schwere komplikationen mit
seinen publikationen dazu gekriegt das
risiko von weiteren todesfällen sei zu
hoch schreiben mehrere mediziner auf der
anderen seite wurden schon fast 2,7
millionen astrazeneca dosen in
deutschland verimpft fast immer ohne
schlimme folgen
wir hatten schon angesprochen der zweite
impfstoff den ist das astra zeneca
angeht ich erinnere mich gut während des
ersten stopps dafür ausgesprochen dass
während dieses impfstoffs aber weiter
der
sozusagen im stoff verabreicht werden
sollte und parallel dazu getestet wird
[Musik]
da getätigt haben also auch jetzt soll
es ja nicht so einem impfstoff kommen
sondern der impfstoff sei weiter gegeben
werden bei den über 60 jährigen
und es soll weiter im stop genommen ja
genauso der impfstoff soll weitergegeben
werden bei den über 60 jährigen bringen
unter 60-jährigen da muss man sich zwar
dass ich nicht mehr zu lauten sondern
also da ist es ganz klar wir sehen jetzt
zum einen die nebenwirkung ist echt das
ist eine also nebenwirkung die ähnlich
funktioniert wie also alle heparin
induzierte paradoxe im turm
thrombozytopenie das ist auch so eine
seltene nebenwirkungen wie man auch bei
der epa riad und offenbar ist das
protein hier so also morphologisch zu
betrachten das ist ähnlich also an bord
an diesem rezept wie heparin und bei
denjenigen die ihr zu dieser seltenen
reaktion also neigen also dann dieser
konkurse bekommen noch insbesondere sie
nutzen und somit ihr wissen mittlerweile
dass das risiko echt ist und wir können
sagen es ist mehr als als 200.000 von
den jüngeren
somit braucht man da jetzt nicht mehr zu
warten sondern in der tat ist es dann
wäre dafür die immer noch attraktiv wie
im stoff haben es ist einfach sinnvoll
an den schlussstrich hier zumachen und
sagen bei den unter 60-jährigen kann
daneben steht zwar noch freiwillig
genommen werden aber wir können ihn
nicht mehr empfehlen
das ist natürlich ein thema und jetzt
wie gesagt auch dieses erneute teilweise
aussetzen was die bevölkerung stark
verunsichert was natürlich auch in
unserer community viele fragen
hervorruft so zum beispiel auch bei jörg
michael über youtube gibt es denn bei
den über 60-jährigen keine thrombosen
kann man das nahezu ausschließen also
die wahrscheinlichkeit sehr gering sein
weil wir haben bisher eine ganz wenige
fälle weil sie über 590 testierten
gesehen und somit ist das risiko hier
deutlich geringer als eins zu 250.000
was ja das risiko war was wir bisher für
die jüngeren sogar angenommen
und haben dort weitergehen also bei den
älteren ist das risiko tatsächlich sehr
gering und den nutzen des lebens stoff
ist gerade in der schweren dritten werde
überwegs ganz dramatisch das ist ganz
klar man kann keiner mehr in welchen
raten hier auf die impfung zu verzichten
nur wegen der nebenwirkungen dafür ist
die nebenwirkung zu selten
herr lauterbach danke für den moment wir
wollen uns ganz kurz anhören was der
bayerische gesundheitsminister klaus
holetschek zu diesem thema zu sagen
hatte denn die gesundheitsminister der
länder haben sich ja heute auch
getroffen und auch dazu gibt es eine
stellungnahme
wir wollen noch einmal bekräftigen dass
wir nach wie vor der meinung sind dass
astrazeneca ein wirksamer impfstoff ist
der gegen schwere krankheitsverläufe
nicht und gerade jetzt bei der dritten
welle und der gefahr der mutation ist es
auch notwendig dass dieser impfstoff
eingesetzt wird und wir folgen
einstimmig dem votum der stiko ihn jetzt
an personen über 60 jahre zu finden
die länder haben dabei die möglichkeit
auch in der priorisierung der über
60-jährigen jetzt abzuweichen und die
nächste gruppe mit aufzumachen das
bleibt den ländern überlassen im rahmen
ihres regimes
soweit also die einlassung von
gesundheitsminister klaus holetschek aus
bayern herr lauterbach haben sie dem
noch irgendwas hinzuzufügen
das ist also das ist tatsächlich jetzt
die beschlusslage und was man hier macht
also quasi damit man beruf ältere findet
ihr es also er sofort in den wünschen
öffnet man quasi die also risikogruppe
drei dass 60 bis 70 jährigen dass die
ebenfalls schon geimpft werden können
werden die länder also sich für diesen
weg entscheiden
ich persönlich kann nur davor warnen
dass an also sie im freien folge zu
stark verwässert das aber
nichtsdestotrotz ich glaube dass dem
stoff in der gänze hier also gut
genommen werden wenn wir hier ehrlich
und transparent aufklären was ich sehr
gut gemacht hat und daher denke ich
anders ist das ein überschaubarer
rückschlag für unsere kampagne wir haben
wird um nicht mehr und nicht weniger
impfstoff zur verfügung
ich glaube es wird uns des kahlen astens
auflegen
ja das ist eine hoffnung die sie haben
aber man muss trotzdem finde ich noch
mal festhalten das ist das lange doch
ein ziemliches durcheinander war mit
diesem impfstoff zunächst war die
empfehlung mangels daten ihnen nicht an
menschen über 65 jahren zu verabreichen
nun also genau das gegenteil das ist
natürlich schwierig zu vermitteln wie
will man da die bevölkerung mitnehmen
und jetzt doch wieder das vertrauen auch
herstellen einfach durch ehrlichkeit man
muss bescheiden wie es ist ich habe die
entscheidung den ich so oft bei den über
65-jährigen nicht einzusetzen also die
ich gehe ja damals getroffen hatte das
hat mich also nie überzeugt weil es
macht auch aus der perspektive vieler
spezialisten und beobachten erfahrene
konstanten keinen sinn weil den
impfstoff da nicht anzusetzen wo er den
größten nutzen also einen stoff der
schützt ja also bei den älteren jemanden
der 1 600 fahrer des kombi todesrisiko
hat wenn er 80 ist im vergleich zu einem
30 jährigen und somit auch so war es
wahrscheinlich von anfang an fragwürdig
dass man den astra impfstoff wir gerade
bei den älteren nicht einsetzt weil in
jüngern ist seine sache
weil da hatte ich mir nebenwirkungen
aber weil der held dann war da noch
immer gut lanciert
das ganze war das muss man ja auch sagen
eine europäische entscheidung also die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde hat da
eine einschätzung abgegeben muss die
sich jetzt also revidieren oder sehen
sie da jetzt auch vertrauen gefährdet
was diese institution angeht die
europäische arzneimittelbehörde hatte ja
im gegensatz zur stiko die einschränkung
für ältere nicht vorgenommen also der
die einschränkung als signal an alle
anstalten wie von der stiko gekommen ist
und die europäische arzneimittelbehörde
hat den impfstoff immer bei den über
60-jährigen also über 65-jährigen
erfüllen und die anstrengungen die wir
jetzt hier in deutschland machen für die
jüngeren basieren im wesentlichen noch
der grund basieren wesentlichen auf
daten die auch in deutschland gesammelt
haben und somit ist das eine gute
entscheidung ich glaube dass die stiko
am anfang einen fehler gemacht hat war
der einzige zu werden impfstoff bekommen
sollte aber mittlerweile da so
aber noch der höhe sache ist und was die
heutige entscheidung richtig
eine frage die sie oft an uns
herangetragen wird ich stelle sie jetzt
mal für julia schaefers über youtube was
ist wenn ich meine erste impfung schon
erhalten habe also vermutlich eben mit
astrazeneca was ist dann mit der zweiten
impfung was wenn sie zb zu dieser
risikogruppe gehört noch unter 60 unter
55 jahren ist was ist dann mit ihr
also hat man zwei möglichkeiten man kann
die zweite impfung mit astrein außerdem
gegen nehmen oder man wartet ab ob es
eine zulassung für bei entdeckt für die
zweite impfung geben wird es wird
derzeit in einer großen studie in
england geprüft und dann liegen die
ergebnisse aber noch nicht vor und kann
man quasi war man ja bei dem fast auf
insgesamt nach dem punkt 12 von mir das
noch zeit hat also mit zweite impfung
hier kann man abwarten bis diese studie
vorliegt oder man nimmt die 2008
ich persönlich würde die zweite impfung
also mit anfrage wir werden die ersten
punkt gefunden hat auf jeden fall
weiterempfehlen können weil das risiko
sehr niedrig ist auch bei den jüngeren
das heißt das risiko 1 zu 100000 darauf
dass bei der zweiten dann nochmal also
so hoch ist wenn man die erste gut
vertragen als eher unwahrscheinlich
eine solche reaktion wurde sich dann in
erster linie auch schon bei der ersten
impfung zeigen aber wie gesagt man kann
da abwarten wollen man hat ja noch ein
paar wochen zeit bis die zweite impfung
vorgesehen ist und vielleicht sind bis
dahin die daten aus der studie teil und
weg nach us-recht ich wort liegen diese
daten vor das was jetzt in uk was also
versucht vielleicht kann man das auch
noch mal grundsätzlich kehren erklären
wenn probleme auftauchen im zusammenhang
mit dem impfstoff dann meistens recht
schnell nach verabreichung des selben
oder gebraucht genauso ist es dass die
probleme treten typischerweise also nach
wenigen tagen auf und spätestens nach
den ersten 14 tagen und also ganz
typische symptome sind hier sehr starke
kopfschmerzen übelkeit kann
bekommen es kann zu schwindel bekommen
und es kann auch zu bestimmten nase haut
bekommen die darauf hinweist dass der
thrombozyten abfall also stattgefunden
hat somit also diese kombination
hautveränderungen kleine fleckchen und
auch sehr starke kopfschmerzen und
außerdem zeit von 4 bis 14 tage nach der
irgendwo das werdet mir verdächtig dann
müsste man sich sofort mit spezialisten
in kontakt bringen aber wie gesagt also
ersten reaktionen rahmen zum fazit wenn
dann der früh mit die allerneusten die
die impfung jetzt bekommen habe
mit so einer wahrscheinlichkeit von mehr
als 900 90,9 prozent haben sie noch
nicht nur gut vertragen sondern daran
dass ich auch nichts mehr
gut dass sich die symptome auch nochmal
geschildert haben auf die man achten
sollte ina hönicke schreibt uns über
facebook das ist das problem wenn zeug
geimpft wird das nicht ausreichend mit
langjährigen studien getestet wurde
man kommt sich vor wie versuchskaninchen
wie soll man als bürger dann noch
vertrauen haben
nun kann man das vielleicht so auch
nicht stehen lassen meiner information
nach wurden immerhin 12.000 probanden in
die studie miteinbezogen natürlich nicht
über lange jahre das hat die zeit nicht
gereicht aber dass man es nicht getestet
hätte stimmt auch nicht
nein in der tat wenn man den impfstoff
länger entwickelt hätte hätte man für
die phase 3 studie auch nicht mehr
patienten in die studie einbringen
können und somit ist das verfahren hier
zwar schneller gewesen aber nicht
weniger sicher
das bedeutet das also dieser
nebenwirkung die wir jetzt sehe diese
sehr sehr sehr seltene nebenwirkungen
sie sehe ich nur im routineeinsatz wo
millionen menschen in der neben softer
an bekommen und in eine solche millionen
testung trete ich auch jetzt nach zehn
jahren also mit die schnelle entwicklung
ist impfstoffes habt ihr nichts dazu
sagen ich muss noch mal darauf hinweisen
wir sehen solche komplikationen auch in
dieser größenordnung auch bei anderen
impfstoffen wie überall aber natürlich
sind die korona impfstoffe jetzt
besonders sozusagen im brennglas des
interesse ist oder unter diesen wir
wollen gerade nochmal einen weiteren o
ton hören der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder auch er
hat sich geäußert zur thematik und
natürlich geht es auch bei ihnen darum
das vertrauen wieder zu gewinnen bzw
vielleicht auch seiner skepsis ausdruck
zu verleihen wir wollen uns nochmal
anhören was er heute gesagt hat bei
astrazeneca habe ich einfach insgesamt
kein gutes gefühl was diese ganzen
einschätzung betrifft also wer was
empfiehlt nicht geht er hin und her
würden wann wird man basterds weniger
speziell mit sehr viel freiheit
operieren müssen und irgendwann sagen
müssen wer will und wer sich traut quasi
das nun auch die möglichkeit haben den
fakt ist bei allen empfehlungen die
gefahr einer schweren erkrankung ist
viel höher einzuschätzen als mögliche
nebenwirkungen war es weniger so weit
jedenfalls jetzt bekannt und ein
geschützt werden
also herr lauterbach herr söder sagt wer
sich traut quasi soll vortreten
ist das jetzt in ihren augen eine
vertrauenserweckende rhetorik all das
hätte ich so nicht ausgedrückt weil also
das ding das war es immer an speziellen
mut haben müsste sich diesen stoff also
sprechen zu lassen das ist abwegig weil
in der tat also wir haben hier
nebenwirkungen die eine bei den jüngeren
einen von 100000 und dort setzen wir den
impfstoff ab jetzt nicht mehr einfach so
man muss da muss man die kirche im dorf
lassen
bei den eltern ist das risiko ja in der
größenordnung rheins zu 250.000 als
300.000 und wenn ich hier eine sehr
schwere erkrankung also befürchten muss
die älteren die über 50 sind und eine
plakat im stadion mit einer
wahrscheinlichkeit von zwei prozent das
ist sehr nennenswert es gibt weniger
erkrankungen die eine solche
sterblichkeit alterskurve dann ist der
nutzen der impfung überwältigend so das
risiko von 1 3000 eine dann auch
übrigens oft noch besser behandelbar
sinus denen von bose zu bekommen das
hält sich im rahmen und daher finde ich
ist der ist die art und weise wie markus
söders hier ausgedrückt hat unglücklich
aber ich bin sicher dass er damit auch
nicht zum ausdruck bringen wollte
dass der im sommer
und vertretbares risiko dar nein das hat
er glaube ich auch noch mal im
nachfolgenden satz dann deutlich gemacht
sonja bucher schreibt uns über facebook
ich bin 60 wenn ich mich nichts mit
astra impfen lassen will
rutsche ich dann bei einem eventuellen
impftermin nach ganz hinten das wäre
erpressung können sie da diese frage aus
der praxis sozusagen beantworten wie im
cern sie müssen also im moment klären
wie man damit umgeht diese frage ist
noch nicht geklärt auch so wie weit man
dann nach hinten gerückt
das ist also eine offene frage ich bin
selbst also registriert in einigen im
sales und ich weiß dass dort mit diesen
fragen jetzt also in den nächsten
stunden auseinander setzen müssen aber
tatsächlich eine erpressung darauf sie
auf karl verlegen
wir haben folgende frage auch noch
mehrfach jetzt zu hören bekommen bei uns
in den sozialen medien in den
kommentaren da taucht öfter auf die ema
hat den astra zeneca impfstoff schon
umbenannt scheinbar um ihn trotzdem
weiterhin nutzen zu können jetzt heißt
er wachse frühjahr haben sie dazu
irgendwelche erkenntnisse nein das ist
nicht nur das sind also keine
umbenennungen außerdem schon erkennbar
machen sollte von astrid c liga ist
nichts anderes als das unternehmen
was den aus dem stoff also erstellt und
also der name des impfstoffs ist er eben
also von ihnen genannte aber es handelt
sich um die nachteiligen stoff den 18
egal ist ob hier ist keine umbenennung
also vorgenommen worden
die offizielle bezeichnung dieses eben
doch das war in der vergangenheit immer
noch science eben stoff weil sie sich
also adenovirus sozialen gesetzt wird im
pansen wir müssen daher ist die
ursprüngliche bezeichnung da hat man
sich jetzt einen namen für den nämlich
glaubt überlegt aber es ist der
impfstoff von der firma astrazeneca und
da ist das keine und assistent versucht
den impfstoff war sie umzubenennen
um das risiko also zu vernehmen dass iss
abheben
wir sprechen mit karl lauterbach warten
natürlich noch weiter auf die
bundeskanzlerin und gucken immer mit
einem auge rüber zur bühne im kanzleramt
aber noch ist da nichts zu erkennen es
geht um die linie im umgang mit
astrazeneca und sobald sich dort etwas
tut sind wir natürlich dann wieder
zurück herr professor lauterbach ist das
risiko fragt samui
frage noch mal wiederholen haben sie
mich jetzt wieder wieder ja es gibt aber
kein problem
das tut mir leid ich versuche es noch
mal also ich bin der hoffnung dass sie
mich hören können
die frage die ich ihnen geschieht ja die
frage die ich hingestellt habe war ob
denn das risiko nicht zu gering ist das
fragt samui über youtube die impfung für
jüngere zu stoppen also in anbetracht
der relation diese führen ja auch schon
aufgezeigt haben müsste man nicht
trotzdem weiterhin von das so seine
frage
das wäre in der tat die konsequenzen des
ibl nur den einen nicht aufgeht wenn wir
jetzt nur den astra impfstoff hätten
dann würde man auf der grundlage an das
so selten komplikationen den impfstoff
nicht doppelt und würde ihn auch weiter
verwenden und auch bei den jüngeren
aber da wir also impfstoffe haben die
diese komplikation nicht haben gerade
war den jüngeren macht es hier sind dass
man die also im stoff für optimal
einsetzen dass man konzentriert den ast
eigen stoff der bei den eltern genauso
gut wird wie der bayern vergeben ich
darf aber dort die nebenwirkung nicht
hat aus die älteren und bei den jungen
sonden ersetzt man das waren euch den
ball und ergebnis doch wo wir diese
komplikationen da nicht haben
juli punkt fahrt uns über youtube gibt
es eine möglichkeit die thrombosen zu
behandeln falls sie auftreten das wäre
ja auch noch ein wichtiger punkt während
das ist in der tat so wenn man diese
prognose schnell erkennt und daher wird
es jetzt auch eine aufklärung geben von
der deutschen gesellschaft für
immunologie und woran man dass die
thrombose erkennen kann wenn man nicht
um größe schnell erkennt dann kann man
hier tatsächlich auch behandeln
man muss allerdings dazu sagen das ist
keine kleinigkeit dieser behandlung und
das ist dann zentren vorbehalten
aber in der tat werden die behandlung
schnell erfolgt dann kann man hier sehr
erfolgreich war ja also halten wir fest
normalerweise zeigen dich zeigen sich
die symptome schnell und dann sollte
eben auch schnell gehandelt werden um da
auch eine gute behandlung chance zu
haben
juni heinrich über facebook lauterbach
ich bin 27 jahre
männlich kann ich mich am donnerstag
trotzdem mit astrazeneca bei meinem
hausarzt impfen lassen also freiwillig
und männlich ja die freiwillige impfung
ist möglich dass gar keine frage
und das ist hier eine risiko ab jetzt so
ehlert immer so weshalb man geimpft
werden soll wenn man zum beispiel an
beruf tätig ist wo das risiko hoch ist
dann wäre aus meiner sicht dass er diese
freiwillige impfung mit astra durchaus
zu empfehlen
ich würde selbst auch nach wie vor in
dem stoff jeder zahlt neben weil also
das risiko zwar nicht geleugnet werden
kann der nutzer auch im vordergrund
steht jetzt haben sie gesagt sie selbst
würden ihn nehmen würden sie ihn auch
ihrer tochter schwester ihr frau 60
sozusagen empfehlen hand aufs herz
na ja es kommt darauf an was die
alternativen sind dazu werden jetzt
sagen wir junge menschen die möglichkeit
haben auch in bayern der giftstoff zu
bekommen so wie wir das jetzt für die
allgemeine bevölkerung auch vorschlagen
dann würde diese empfehlung natürlich
auch mal einem ratschläge für die eigene
familie entsprechend dass wir gar keine
frage zu machen wir das ja wir machen
das ja weil wir eben also den impfstoff
da einsetzen wollen wir den größten
nutzen und die geringsten nebenwirkungen
hat und diese empfehlung gesichter hat
sich auch mal an der eigenen familie
folgen
wir haben einfach ausgedrückt aus dem
begrenzten impfstoff bekommen sogar
überlegen wo wir welche neben stoff
optimalerweise ansetzen und da ist da
ist ein impfstoff wegen der geringen
nebenwirkungen bei der älteren gruppe
und den hohen nutzen dort besser
platziert als bei den jüngeren
vielleicht noch mal eine allgemeine
frage auch jetzt zum umfang des ausfalls
also der vertrauensverlust ist ja das
eine problem aber es fallen auch
praktisch einfach dadurch jetzt viele
impfdosen weg die eigentlich
vernünftigen werden sollen also
zumindest jetzt für die entsprechenden
personen wie schätzen sie jetzt die
zeitliche verzögerung ein
das ist nur eine kurzfristige also
verzögerung die wir ja hier würde sich
nur ein langfristiges problem erklärt
wenn das so gar nicht mehr eingesetzt
werden
oder wenn es nicht mehr genug
impfwillige gäbe die den nach seinen
stoff haben wollen was sehe ich aber
nicht ich glaube daher dass es eine sehr
kleine delle sein wird die wir sofort
ausgleichen
und dass wir damit nicht in einem
größeren im verzug hineingeraten
doch fragt uns über youtube eine frage
an herrn lauterbach ob es denn bei den
verstorbenen ihrer kenntnis nach sich um
irgendwelche gemeinsamkeiten handelt
vielleicht gemeinsame risikofaktoren
oder dergleichen man dazu legen wir
keine erkenntnisse vor
es scheint aber gerade gemeinsamen
risikofaktoren gegeben zwar von den
gesprächen die ich jetzt hier mit
behandeln und also soll so engagierten
wissenschaftlern geführt habe genauso
ist allerdings auch bei der epa
reduzierten company das ist ja eine
ähnliche komplikation die man bei der
reparieren erwarten sind gibt es auch
keine klar deswegen ein risikofaktor
wir wissen dass das ganze bei jüngeren
menschen etwas häufiger als bei älteren
und verfahren auch etwas häufiger als
bei männern
aber wir wissen noch nicht einmal
weshalb das sowieso das ist weder bei
der analogen also etwa induzierten
company der fall noch hierbei der also
paar songs sind im freistaat ja also man
merkt sie sind ein mann vom fach harfe
also die begriffe versteht vielleicht
nicht ganz jeder auf anhieb aber wir
wollen vielleicht auch noch mal
gemeinsam versuchen mit meinem kollegen
jan frederik fischer zusammen auch
nochmal uns anzuschauen welche seltenen
folgen auftreten können im zusammenhang
mit der impfung dazu noch mal ein paar
einzelheiten keine impfung für menschen
ab 65 jahren mögliche impfungen für alle
erwachsenen ein kurzzeitiger impfstoff
für alle und nun nur eingeschränkt dosen
für unter 60 jährige das hin und her
es verunsichert viele doch wie sind die
impfungen bisher gelaufen fast 2,7
millionen mal ist im stoff bis anfang
der woche verimpft worden bei 31 fällen
diagnostizierten die ärzte nach einer
impfung eine sinus venenthrombose
19 dieser fälle traten probleme mit dem
blutplättchen auf neun menschen starben
der zusammenhang ist jedoch noch nicht
eindeutig bewiesen
betroffen sind fast ausschließlich
frauen im alter zwischen 20 und 63
jahren wichtig jedoch zu wissen nach
einer hochrechnung gegen auch deutlich
mehr als die hälfte aller astrazeneca
impfungen an frauen
wie hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
die nebenwirkung eintritt eigentlich
wären 10,8 fälle bei 2,7 millionen
menschen zu erwarten oh ja doch 31 fälle
in rund sieben wochen ein deutliches
alarmsignal
aber was passiert bei diesen thrombosen
bei den betroffenen personen verklumpt
das blut in den hirnen die folge etwa
ein tödlicher schlaganfall
die gute nachricht eine frühzeitige
diagnose und behandlung ist möglich
mögliche symptome können nach vier bis
16 tagen auftreten
dazu gehören etwas schwindel
kopfschmerzen oder etwas sehstörungen ja
also das noch mal sozusagen zur
illustrierung dessen was wir für den
auch schon besprochen hatten
herr professor lauterbach wir warten
immer noch auf die kanzlerin was
erwarten sie sich denn von dem beschluss
der nun heute abend gefasst wird womit
rechnen sie ich rechne damit dass der
beschluss ungefähr sich an dem entlang
entwickelt was wir besprochen haben dass
also jene die eigentlich die grenze 60
jahre sein wird dass man den impfstoff
bei den unter 60 jährigen nichts vom
markt nimmt sondern einfach nicht mehr
empfiehlt ist aber weiter möglich was in
dem stoff dort zu vereinzeln
freiwilliger was ist dass man
klargestellt dass diejenigen impfstoff
bekommen haben sie keine sorgen machen
müssen der zeit des beschlusses
komplikationen bekommen und dass man
noch klärt das also die zweite impfung
für die basis mit as geben möglich ist
mit dem mauszeiger nicht doch was man
aber auch zu machen kann
bis also in studien geklärt ist ob die
zweitimpfung check durchgeführt werden
kann das wird jetzt hart gegen england
also geprüft aus dieser der fachlichen
information erwarte ich von sonax
minister und dass man auch normal ab
definiert dass man nochmal klaren markt
also
die zum impfstoff astrazeneca stehen
ohne wenn und aber er ist dann erst darf
sich noch für die eltern tat sich dort
in der tat in den letzten wochen um noch
mal eine gute nachricht zu sagen zu
behandeln als nicht gefährlich erwiesen
dass man ursprünglich gedacht hat wird
das in jeden locken die wir treffen nur
jüngere und zum zweiten bei der
wirksamkeit hat der jüngst auf er noch
einmal zugelegt und wir sehen jetzt dass
er also wenn also eher richtig dosiert
also eingesetzt also nach zwölf wochen
also dann ausgewertet wird dass er so
eine wirksamkeit hat die also alle
krankenhausfälle und alle fotos werden
spruch mit vermeidet das ist die größte
maßnahme über die wir sprechen also
wirklich dramatisch also wirkstoffen
also wird sich an den erstklassige
impfung das muss auch klargestellt
werden so dass irgendwo hier nicht ohne
not infrage
christoph christopher schade fragt uns
über facebook gibt es in uk also im
vereinigten königreich großbritannien
zunehmend thrombose fälle also dort auch
oder könnte es an den europäischen
fabriken liegen ist eine sehr gute frage
ganz außen gesagt das wissen wir noch
nicht es ist klar dass also man in
england wieso sinus venenthrombose hier
seht mal gesehen hat als vsg es kann
aber auch daran liegen dass eben doch
dort im wesentlichen bei den älteren
eingesetzt worden ist wo wir die sinus
vielen und thrombose deutschland nicht
so sehen
somit kann es einfach also der tatsache
entsprechen dass also der impfstoff in
england vornehmlich bayern eingesetzt
wurde
dass die art und weise wie
nebenwirkungen daraus gewertet werden er
ist auch etwas grobkörniger so dass der
ein oder andere wahl als industrieland
prognose feiert und möglicherweise als
schlaganfall durch gegangen ist und das
gar nicht die diagnose sie nutzen und
den großen dann mehr hergegeben hat
obwohl es eine war auch das ist möglich
das kann aber auch nicht komplett
ausgeschlossen werden dass es sich hier
umschaut und probleme handelt auch das
wäre denkbar
es ist aber auch so gesagt eher
unrealistisch weibel fragt uns über
youtube oder beziehungsweise bittet sie
das thromboserisiko von astrazeneca im
verhältnis zur pille zu erläutern also
offensichtlich gemeint die antibabypille
ja das kann ich wirklich machen weil die
thrombose die pille was ist eine ganz
andere das sind in der regel also
beinvenenthrombose ab und an kommt auch
eine lungen also thrombose vor
also das sind das sind komplizen
vergleich zu der situation thrombose
überhaupt nicht diese dramatik und somit
auch so in der bilder gibt es sehr viel
mehr
insbesondere bei also bestimmten formen
die www dazu besonders neigen aber man
kann's wirklich nicht vergleichen weil
diese prognosen sind nicht so gefährlich
wie die hier also in rede stehende
singles venenthrombose die also wenn sie
auf folgender verläuft und daher ganz
anders zu gewichten ist ja also herr
professor lothar weiß ich kann nur noch
mal auch danke sagen dass sie uns jetzt
so lange als gesprächspartner zur
verfügung stehen das ist ja eine tolle
sprechstunde die wir hier bieten können
und die haben in der tat viele fragen
teilweise auch recht medizin zb auch
nils m über youtube welcher unterschied
der wirkstoffe im vergleich zu anderen
impfstoffen löst denn dieses problem der
thrombosen aus bei astrazeneca was was
macht anfällig dafür also aus gesprächen
mit spezialisten sagen weil
vorveröffentlichungen die mir bekannten
scheint also das problem tatsächlich
dahin zu legen dass der weg vorgegeben
wird zu einer informatorischen reaktion
führt und dies in der kombination also
dass das protein eine bestimmte
ähnlichkeit hat also mit dem reparieren
rezept oder an die zellen andockt in
dieser kombination kann es hier an einem
sogenannten epitope anderem oberflächen
der protein zu einer reaktion kommen die
quasi paradoxerweise wie thrombose
anregt das ist das problem
aber es offenbar eine kombination rektor
wirkung der vector wirkt also hier also
inflammatorische und in diesem
inflammatorischen umfeld konnte es dann
zu dieser ich sage mal fehlschaltungen
die ausgelöst wird durch eine
morphologische ähnlichkeit des proteins
mit einem rezeptor protein am reparieren
und daher auch diese ähnlichkeit mit der
epa reduzierten trophy vom zob nie
erwähnen dass der mechanismus sein
sollte dann würde also ist
möglicherweise sinnvoll sagen dass man
die vector menge also reduziert das
eigens doch hat eine relativ hohe rektor
dosis und außer in der tat hat man sogar
etwas mehr wirksamkeit gesehen als der
impfstoff versehentlich im rahmen der
studie mit der halben dosis gespritzt
wurde
es kann also sogar sein dass in einer
späteren aus der nutzung des stoffes mit
entweder einem anderen sektor gearbeitet
wird oder einer grille und dosierung das
sind aber jetzt überlegungen die von
us-spezialisten also angestellt werden
das führt hier zu weit man kann auch
sagen es hat also einfach mit dem weg
gott zu tun der in der information macht
und im umfeld dieser implantation
contest dann zu dieser paradoxen
reaktionen die wiederum über das flotte
ihn also vermittelt wird aufmerksam
zugehört
im stecker ich hoffe dass wir keine
tonprobleme jetzt halte das hier ganz
fest mit meinen händen
herr lauterbach ich bin quasi schon ein
bisschen am ende mit meinen fragen sehe
aber dass die bundeskanzlerin immer noch
nicht da ist wir hatten damit gerechnet
dass sie etwas früher vor die presse
tritt offensichtlich zögert sich das
ganze noch etwas hinaus verlangt
abschließende frage weil es mich selber
auch um eben keine oder können sie
hoffnung machen dass auch dieses problem
was die mutanten des impfstoffs bzw dass
wir uns natürlich angeht auch von den
impfstoffen die wir zur verfügung haben
in absehbarer zeit auch in den griff
bekommen werden können
ja in der tat also gibt es also erstmal
hinweis darauf dass die impfstoffe die
wir jetzt haben auf zumindest in teilen
gegen die mutanten die sich gebildet
haben
insbesondere die also britische die
südafrikanische sind auch die
brasilianische wirken heute ist nicht
nur der schienen die gezeigt hat dass
tatsächlich also lebens offen bei der
brasilianischen mutation vielleicht doch
etwas besser wirken dazu bisher fürchten
mussten
ist ja bekannt dass die südafrika nicht
und die preise ja nicht mutationen hier
also gefürchtet sind war dort impfstoffe
wenig aufwertung noch vorher kannten
nicht so gut schützt wie das bei der
ursprungs war für uns auch bei der
britischen variante b ans aktiven der
fall ist aber so können also davon
ausgehen dass wir hier genug wirkung
habe noch zumindest die schwersten fälle
zu verhindern und wir werden die
impfstoffe sehr schnell anpassen können
daran wird jetzt schon fieberhaft
gearbeitet
ich teile da nie geahnt jetzt von herrn
schaden der aus wo sich dazu ja auch den
letzten tagen noch einmal geäußert hat
ähnliches durchaus modernes und dass die
weiterentwicklung der irgendwie gelingen
wird und dass wir bei den nach impfungen
das sind ja nicht die letzte impfung
seien für hoch ist dass wir bald danach
in funktionieren stoffe verwenden können
wo ihr die mutationen in den griff
bekommen werden sich nicht noch weitere
mutationen entwickeln
und da hat es selbst in der hand die
weniger fälle wir haben bis die
bevölkerung geimpft ist desto geringer
das risiko dass sich noch gefährliche
mutationen in deutschland aufhalten
daher also müssen wir schnell auf dieser
seite werden den griff bekommen so dass
wir nicht in eine massive welle
aber es ist natürlich auch der umgang
mit dem virus im ausland gerade in
brasilien vor ein paar tagen bei uns im
heute-journal ein eindrücklicher beitrag
darum wie eben dort auch mit dem virus
umgegangen wird beziehungsweise was
vielleicht auch von seiten der regierung
dort versäumt wird und wenn sich dann
die mutationen weiter ausbreiten oder
note geben
[Musik]
trotzdem ganz herzlich das werden wir
ihnen gleich nochmal nachricht danke
dass sie so lange zur verfügung
gestanden haben wir schauen noch mal auf
das bild im kanzleramt und sehen dass
ich da aber immer noch nichts tut
und sobald die kanzlerin ja natürlich
dabei sein und werden weitermachen mit
unserem stream so lange schauen wir uns
das bild an und wir hoffen dass es dann
gleich weiter geht also
[Musik]
so und wie wir gerade sehen beschreibt
die bundeskanzlerin unter gesunde
bundesgesundheitsminister das podium wir
geben direkt rüber nach berlin im
einsatz des astra zeneca impfstoffs
veröffentlicht es sind empfehlungen die
sie nach intensiven beratungen auch
mitglieder der ethikkommission mit der
nationalen akademie der wissenschaften
leopoldina waren in den vergangenen
tagen mit dem thema befasst erarbeitet
und beschlossen hat ich darf ihnen
zunächst wegen der bedeutung des
sachverhalts auch im wortlaut auszüge
aus der empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission vortragen ich zitiere auf
basis der derzeit verfügbaren allerdings
noch begrenzten evidenz und unter
berücksichtigung der pandemischen lage
empfiehlt die ständige impfkommission
die kogit 19 maxim astrazeneca für
personen im alter über 60 jahre zu
verwenden
ihr einsatz unterhalb dieser
altersgrenze bleibt indes nach
ärztlichem ermessen und bei
individueller risiko akzeptanz nach
sorgfältiger aufklärung möglich zitat
ende
zu der frage wie es für die personen
weiter geht die bereits eine erste
impfung mit astrazeneca bekommen haben
hat die ständige impfkommission die
lehrerempfehlung festgehalten noch mal
ein zitat hin sich jetzt zweiten
impfstoffdosis für jüngere personen die
bereits eine erste dosis der kogit 19
vakzine astrazeneca erhalten haben wird
die ständige impfkommission bis ende
april stellung nehmen
zitat ende bis dahin werden sie für
diese frage notwendige studien
ausgewertet haben
und ich füge hinzu dann wird klar sein
mit welchem der in deutschland
zugelassenen impfstoffe auch für diesen
personenkreis der volle impfschutz
erreicht wird über die folgen die sie
aus der neuen empfehlung der ständigen
impfkommission zum astrazeneca impfstoff
in deutschland und zur impfkampagne
insgesamt ergeben hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister am frühen
abend zunächst mit den
gesundheitsministerin
gestern der bundesländer beraten vorhin
haben der bundesgesundheitsminister und
ich die lager dann auch mit den
regierungschefinnen und regierungschefs
der bundesländer beraten die beratung
des gerade zu ende gegangen dabei haben
wir festgehalten die empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission beruhen auf
erkenntnissen die fachleute in den
vergangenen wochen über sehr seltene
gleichwohl sehr schwere fälle von
thrombosen bei mit astrazeneca diensten
personen gesammelt haben
es sind erkenntnisse die die ständige
impfkommission und damit schließlich
auch wir nicht ignorieren können
deshalb haben bund und länder heute
abend entschieden der empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission zu folgen
wir unterrichten natürlich darüber auch
die e mail sowie die whu wir alle wissen
dass impfen ist das wichtigste
hilfsmittel gegen das corona virus dass
wir verschiedene impfstoffe zur
verfügung haben das ist ein großes glück
und es ist und bleibt eine gewaltige
leistung der wissenschaft wir stehen
auch heute abend nicht vor der frage
astrazeneca oder keinen impfstoff
sondern wir haben verschiedene
impfstoffe zur verfügung
wir wissen aber auch dass ganze impfen
das alles beruht auf einem grundsatz und
das ist vertrauen
wir müssen den impfstoffen vertrauen
können und deswegen warten wir bis jeder
impfstoff das zulassungsverfahren des
der sogenannten bedingten zulassung
durchlaufen hat deswegen setzen wir nur
impfstoffe ein die die europäische
zulassung haben wozu auch die
anschließende fortlaufende prüfung ihrer
wirksamkeit und sicherheit die
permanente abwägung von risiken und
nutzen gehört vertrauen entsteht aus dem
wissen dass jedem verdacht jedem
einzelfall nachgegangen wird
dafür stehen bund und länder ein die nun
neuen regeln für den einsatz von
astrazeneca haben natürlich auch folgen
für die organisation der impfkampagne in
der
nächsten zeit auch darüber haben wir
heute beraten wir werden veränderungen
an den leaf ablehnen vornehmen müssen an
der verteilung auf impfzentren auf
mobile teams und gleich nach ostern auch
auf die hausärzte
das werden wir bund und länder und die
vielen engagierten kräfte in den
kommunen gemeinsam anpacken und
bewältigen
die gesundheitsminister haben dazu
sollte schon erste empfehlungen gegeben
und mit den immer größeren lieferungen
an impfstoffen wird die impfkampagne
immer weiter forciert und wir werden
schritt für schritt auch das kann ich
heute abend noch einmal wiederholen die
pandemie überwinden können
herzlichen dank frau bundeskanzlerin
meine damen und herren die neue
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
zur impfung mit astrazeneca hat zwei
seiten einerseits zeigt sie die
bürgerinnen und bürger können sich
darauf verlassen dass in deutschland
zugelassene eben stoffe akribisch
überwacht werden und dass die ergebnisse
dieser überwachung auch transparent
gemacht und transparent diskutiert
werden das zeigt im übrigen auch dass
die entscheidung vorletzte woche nachdem
der erste erkenntnisse auch in größerem
zusammenhang hatten dass es plausibel
sein kann dass es einen zusammenhang
zwischen den impfungen mit astra zyniker
und dieser sehr seltenen aber doch auch
sehr speziellen form der hier in wien
thrombose geben kann dass es richtig war
dann auszusetzen und sich erst einmal
ein bild zur lage zu machen
andererseits ist es ohne frage ein
rückschlag dass bei einem unserer
verfügbaren impfstoffe in dieser
pandemie für eine bestimmte altersgruppe
offenbar ein erhöhtes risiko besteht
bis gestern wurden 31 fälle einer hirn
venenthrombose nach impfungen mit dem
cupid 19 impfstoff von astra zyniker
gemeldet neun davon verliefen leider
tödlich
fast alle fälle betrafen frauen und in
geringerem maße auch männer unter 60
jahren
deswegen ist es richtig dass sich die
ständige impfkommission zu gemeinsam mit
anderen expertinnen und experten im
engen austausch noch einmal mit dem
thema auseinandergesetzt hat und ihre
empfehlungen angepasst hat ich danke
unseren expertinnen und experten beim
paul-ehrlich-institut
und in der ständigen impfkommission
ausdrücklich für die sorgfältige und
gewissenhafte prüfung der ereignisse
rund um astra celica und ich will auch
hinzufügen dass uns sehr bewusst ist den
kolleginnen und kollegen in den ländern
auch der ministerpräsident
ministerpräsidenten allen beteiligten in
der bundesregierung was eine solche
entscheidung für die auch einfach das
tägliche geschehen in dem impfzentrum
auch an einem tag wie heute bedeutet
wenn die meldungen kommen dass da
unsicherheiten entstehen dass viel
informations und nachfrage bedarf
entsteht und dass wir das natürlich auch
bestmöglich und transparent adressieren
wollen die empfehlung das haben sowohl
haben wir sowohl erst mit dem
gesundheitsministerium und
gesundheitsministern und gerade eben
auch mit den ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten erörtert diese
empfehlung werden wir werden die länder
ab morgen in der impfkampagne übernehmen
und umsetzen wenn es jetzt schon so ist
hilft die nüchterne betrachtung
das bedeutet dass jetzt die über
60-jährigen schneller geimpft werden
können wir haben im übrigen auch
vereinbart dass die länder jetzt schon
auch mit diesem impfstoff die 60 bis 69
jährigen in ihre impfkampagne mit
einbeziehen können die eltern die
älteren in dieser wachsenden dritten
welle schneller zu schützen ist wichtig
und hilft auch leben zu schützen und
insofern kann ich alle über 60 jährigen
tatsächlich ausdrücklich nur bitten
dieses angebot auch wahrzunehmen
und tatsächlich auch die über
60-jährigen die vorbild sein können in
dieser impfkampagne auch als solche sich
nun ist frühzeitig impfen zu lassen
wichtig ist mir dass der impfstoff sehr
wirksam ist das ist immer wieder wichtig
auch zu betonen auch mit blick auf die
vorfälle die wir jetzt diskutieren das
ändert nichts an der hohen wirksamkeit
dieses impfstoffes übrigens gerade auch
bei den älteren die studien aus
schottland haben gezeigt dass der
impfstoff an astra zyniker gerade bei
den älteren ein besonders wirksamer ist
unter den jüngeren kann jede und jeder
selbst mit dem arzt in einer
entscheidung für sich abwägen ob sie
oder er sich mit astra zenica impfen
lassen
will oder nicht wichtig ist dabei dass
dieses abwägen informiert und aufgeklärt
passiert und dass eben dann auch
entsprechend dokumentiert ist wichtig
ist der hinweis zu zweit im funk ich
will noch mal wiederholen weil ich weiß
dass 2,2 millionen menschen unter 60 die
bereits eine erste impfung mit astra
zenica erhalten haben sich jetzt
natürlich die frage stellen was bedeutet
das für meine zweite impfung wir haben
anfang februar mit der astra zenica
impfung in deutschland begonnen
das empfohlene intervall derzeit die
zeitspanne zwischen erster und zweiter
im fond sind neun bis zwölf wochen zwölf
wochen von anfang februar als anfang mai
das heißt die erstimpfung mit ihrer
wirksamkeit besteht mindestens bis
anfang mai auch fort wir wollen jetzt
zügig mit den fachleuten mit den
experten erörtern wie eine mögliche
zweite impfung ob mit einem anderen eben
stoff in welchem schema dann auch
sichergestellt werden kann ganz wichtig
ist aber die botschaft jeder und jede
wird auch ein impf angebot bekommen das
zur vollen schutzwirkung führt und
führen kann
im übrigen kann natürlich jeder der
unter 60-jährigen für sich entscheiden
unter abwägung aller informationen die
zweitimpfung die angeboten wird auch mit
astra zenica anzunehmen insgesamt geht
es um ein abwägen zwischen den risiken
einer nebenwirkung die statistisch
gering aber ernst zu nehmen ist und dem
risiko an krebs zu erkranken und einen
schweren verlauf oder langzeit folgen
der krankheit zu erleiden und in dieser
abwägung da sind sich unsere expertinnen
und experten sehr einig gilt eines sehr
klar impfen ist fast immer die bessere
entscheidung
frau bundeskanzlerin ist ja das problem
dass bei astrazeneca zunächst die
anwendungs vorgabe genau andersherum war
dass man gesagt hat für jüngere jahr und
für ältere nein mir ist bekannt dass das
damals für eine datenlage gelegen hat
jetzt ist es genau andersrum ältere
sollen ihn bekommen jüngere nicht wer
sich jetzt nicht so sehr damit
beschäftigt könnte davon schon verwirrt
werden können glauben sie nicht dass das
vertrauen in diesen impfstoff durch
diesen vorfall weiter gelitten hat und
herr spahn eine detailfrage es soll ja
jetzt bei den unter 60-jährigen möglich
sein sich nach individueller
individuelle risikoanalyse und beratung
den impfstoff trotzdem spritzen zu
lassen allerdings nur beim hausarzt wie
können sie den gewährleisten dass die
hausärzte jetzt in nächster zeit auch
über die notwendigen im stoßen verfügen
also man muss sich die frage stellen was
sind die alternativen und natürlich
hätten wir uns alle gewünscht dass am
anfang die datenlage auch für die
älteren schon da gewesen wäre und b wir
heute nicht vor ihnen stehen würden und
ihnen die mit die entscheidung der
ständigen impfkommission mit teilen
müssten
zweitens was ist dann die alternative
natürlich werden menschen sich fragen
was passiert da und was bedeutet das
jetzt für mich und jens spahn hat ja
insbesondere auf die über zwei millionen
geimpften hingewiesen und natürlich auch
menschen die als sich jetzt auf einen
impftermin gefreut haben dass alles wird
verunsicherung mit sich bringen aber
womit wird das vertrauen mehr
erschüttert so etwas unter den teppich
zu kehren nicht ernst zu nehmen oder die
fälle die auftreten und es sind
impfstoffe die eben noch nicht jahrelang
im einsatz sind sondern die jetzt auch
in der großen zahl ja erst die
erkenntnisse
wir haben wenn große zahlen von menschen
geimpft werden wenn wir dieses vertrauen
dadurch erschüttern würden dass wir das
was wir wissen und dass die ständige
impfkommission das was sie weiß nicht
ernst nimmt und deshalb glaube ich unter
allen abwägungen ist dies der weg der
noch zudem möglichst besten vertrauen
führt auf dem weg zu einer verwendung
von astrazeneca wenngleich ich die um
verunsicherung nicht wegreden kann aber
offenheit ist glaube ich die beste und
transparenz die beste möglichkeit mit
einer solchen situation umzugehen
dem kann ich mich ausdrücklich nur
anschließen ich denke der weg den wir
gewählt haben und den wir wählen und
auch bei jedem anderen vergleichbaren
fall jeder vergleichbaren situationen
wellen werden dass vor allem der von
transparenz informationen und dann auf
jeweils der wissens lage ich kriege ja
auch die frage was ist jetzt anders als
vor zwei wochen
wir wissen mehr wir haben mehr gemeldete
fälle wir haben einen besseren überblick
es gibt austausch mit anderen ländern
wir sind ja im übrigen wenn sie den
vergleichen mit anderen ländern auch
nicht das einzige land in europa und auf
der welt kanada heute das eben auf basis
der datenlage zu dieser entscheidung
kommt
das ziel für die frage wie gehen wir mit
den impfdosen um das unbedingte ziel
muss sein möglichst viele der über 60
jährigen der über 70-jährigen jetzt auch
gerade in dieser wachsenden dritten
welle zu impfen um sie zu schützen weil
ihr leider insbesondere höheres alter
auch ein höher
risiko im falle einer kurve 19
erkrankung mit sich bringt und deswegen
geht es darum dass mit den über zwei
millionen impfdosen 1,7 millionen
übrigens jetzt am osterwochenende die
noch an die länder ausgeliefert werden
auch auf jeden fall mit astrid von
astrazeneca auch zügig verkauft werden
und es werden sich da bin ich sehr
sicher hinreichend viele über 60 jährige
gerne schützen lassen mit diesem
impfstoff und deswegen ist auch wichtig
dass das passiert und im übrigen gilt
auch für die impfungen in den arztpraxen
das aus meiner sicht mit astrazeneca
zuerst und zuvörderst die über
60-jährigen geimpft werden sollten ob in
den impfzentren oder den arztpraxen
dieser impfstoff von dem wir allein in
den ersten beiden quartalen im ersten
halbjahr über 20 millionen dosen
erwarten mit der empfehlung die wir
jetzt haben macht ja unbedingt sinn
vornehmlich jetzt auch einzusetzen bei
den über 60-jährigen er weil wir ihn im
dort auch hauptsächlich mit dieser
empfehlung nur einsetzen können und
dafür andere impfstoffe dann stärker
auch bei den unter 60-jährigen
einzusetzen das gilt gleichfalls ist
jetzt egal ob in der im zentrum oder in
der arztpraxis das prinzip ist das
gleiche
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben vor allem
über das impfen gesprochen heute aber
die menschen draußen interessiert schon
auch ihre aussage vom wochenende da
haben sie kritik an den länder an
manchen ländern geübt im vorgehen gegen
die pandemie und gesagt sie würden sich
überlegen was zu tun sei ist dieser
prozess abgeschlossen und werden sie vom
bund her zum beispiel das
infektionsschutzgesetz nun angreifen und
das an sich ziehen
danke ich habe am wochenende deutlich
gemacht was immer man für einen weg
wählt immer müssten bund und länder
zusammenarbeiten dass das mal die erste
botschaft es gibt keine einzige
politische entscheidungen in deutschland
die nicht zwischen bund und ländern
gemeinsam getroffen werden kann ob das
bundestag und bundesrat sind auch dass
die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz mit der
bundesregierung ist dass es immer das
gleiche der prozess des denkens
nachdenkens ist noch nicht abgeschlossen
ich weiß nur dass es wichtig ist
angesichts der dritten welle in der wir
sind alles zu tun um diese welle
möglichst schnell zu brechen
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin jetzt
ist ja vertrauen tatsächlich weiter
verloren gegangen und und astrazeneca
ist ist für manche glaube ich jetzt so
was wie eine heiße kartoffel
wie wollen sie den versuchen abgesehen
von dem was sie jetzt gerade gesagt
haben das vertrauen bei den leuten in
astra c neckar wieder herzustellen
durch eine kampagne oder dergleichen und
an den gesundheitsminister noch kurz die
frage wenn man jetzt sagt auch 60 bis 69
jährige dürfen sich können sich mit
austrat 10 egger abweichend von der
bisherigen priorisierung impfen lassen
was ist denn wenn die nicht wollen
müssen sie sich dann ganz hinten wieder
anstellen oder kommen die dann eben in
zwei monaten wieder dran
ja ich kann nur noch mal wiederholen
dass wir alles tun durch transparenz
durch informationen durch klarheit und
da bin ich auch der ständigen
impfkommission und allen fachleuten die
daran mitarbeiten sehr dankbar
dieses vertrauen so herzustellen dass
wir nichts hinterm berg halten dass wir
die informationen klar geben und das ist
glaube ich das was der richtige weg ist
in einer solchen situation das sind
alles neu entwickelte impfstoffe sie
haben wie es schon sagt eine bedingte
zulassung wlan jeden tag dazu über den
charakter dieser impfstoffe und wir
müssen dann jedesmal abgewogen auch die
entscheidung treffen beziehungsweise die
wissenschaftler und fachleute müssen
diese treffen und wir tun als politik
gut daran das zu übernehmen das haben
wir bei der unterbrechung der impfung
gemacht das haben wir nach der
entscheidung der ema gemacht und das
machen wir jetzt nach der entscheidung
der ständigen impfkommission auch zu der
frage der über 60 jährigen ist es ja
wichtig dass für die 60 bis 69 jährigen
die sozusagen der nächsten priorisierung
gruppe wären nur im moment der impfstoff
astra zenica dann zur verfügung steht
die länder entscheidet das natürlich
jetzt auch in die rems kampagne einige
länder sind bei der impfung der 70
jährigen schon relativ weit und bei dem
empfang geburt an die 70 jährigen andere
fangen gerade an mit den über
70-jährigen das hat zum teil auch
übrigens mit demografischen unterschiede
zu tun es gibt länder auch mit höheren
durchschnittsalter als andere und das
ist sozusagen jetzt auch ein
pragmatischer ansatz mit diesen
impfstoff auch ein angebot machen zu
können schon jetzt auch darüber hinaus
für die 60 bis 69 jährigen weil auch für
die das zeigen alle daten eben ein
höheres risiko besteht nicht so hoch wie
bei 80 jährige deswegen abgestuft aber
ein erhöhtes risiko besteht und das ist
jetzt sozusagen der anreiz und die
möglichkeit auch dann schneller
auch in der altersgruppe schon geimpft
werden zu können mit astrazeneca mit
einem ich sage es noch einmal weil es
ist sehr wichtig dass der teil der
botschaft auch
mit transportiert ist mit einem sehr
wirksamen impfstoff gerade auch für die
älteren die daten aus schottland england
zeigen dass das teilweise in manchen
aspekten es sogar wirksamer ist als der
von beyond eck bei den älteren
der impfstoff von astra zenica und
insofern soll er dort jetzt auch zum
einsatz kommen und das idealerweise
zügig
frau bundeskanzlerin sind nun sind sie
vom gesundheitsminister gerade
aufgefordert worden sich auch impfen zu
lassen weil sie über 60 sind deswegen
hätte ich ganz gerne von ihnen gewusst
werden sie sich jetzt mit astrazeneca
impfen lassen
und glauben sie eine nachfrage zu der
frage von herrn plank der csu chef hat
heute gesagt das sei sehr ungewöhnlich
dass die cdu-kanzlerin sich mit dem
cdu-chef im wahljahr streitet was sagen
sie zu diesem vorwurf
ich habe jetzt mit dem was ich herrn
lang zu einem land gesagt habe im
augenblick nichts hinzuzufügen und
ansonsten habe ich gesagt wenn ich dran
bin lasse ich mich impfen auch mit
astrazeneca nun kann es sein dass ich
dran bin ich muss mal gucken wie berlin
das handhabt ich die länder priorisieren
das ja es kann ja auch sein in berlin
sagt noch einige tage erst nur die 70
jährigen aber die möglichkeit sich
impfen zu lassen ist für mich näher
gerückt das ist richtig dankeschön
also das versprechen meinen sie im
sommer alle games zu haben damit das
nicht im bis zum ende des sommers im
sommer damit dass jetzt nicht
unbeantwortet bleibt dann noch in
schneller ergänzung weil sie eine
wichtige botschaft ist ja wir rechnen im
zweiten quartal mit jetzt mit der
johnson johnson lieferungen die
angekündigt ist mit 70 millionen
impfdosen davon sind um die 15 millionen
astra zenica und das gibt uns die
möglichkeit schon im zweiten quartal
einen deutlichen unterschied zu machen
zum ersten quartal und es gibt uns wenn
die lieferzusagen eingehalten werden und
alle impfstoffe ihre zulassung erhalten
wie geplant auch die möglichkeit im
sommer und bis zum ende des sommers im
dritten quartal im laufe des dritten
quartals alle zu impfen
über 60 und unter 60 nur die kinder noch
nicht nur die kinder noch nicht
soweit also die bundeskanzlerin und der
bundesgesundheitsminister ich sehe im
hintergrund schon christoph spinner mit
ihm sprechen wenngleich er ist vom
klinikum rechts der isar ich bin noch
ganz kurz zusammenfassen was wir gerade
gehört haben also die bundeskanzlerin
hat betont dass sich die regierung der
empfehlung der stiko anschließt das
bedeutet für die 60 jährigen also die
über 60 jährigen bleibt es im
wesentlichen dabei dass man sich weiter
mit astrazeneca impfen lassen soll bei
60 soll es vermehrte beratungen geben
und dann sei eine freiwillige einigung
immer noch möglich oder einwilligung
aber eben kein muss und die stiko wird
sich auch noch mal äußern bis ende april
was mit leuten ist die jetzt ihre zweite
impfung mit astrazeneca bekommen sollen
die zu der risikogruppe gehören und die
schon die erste impfung bekommen haben
so ihren sparen noch ganz kurz war
wichtig sagte er dass man mit derart
ausgesetzt hat ohne frage sei dies jetzt
ein rückschlag in der impfkampagne aber
er hat es auf der versuch positiv zu
sehen dann für die älteren menschen
zumindest für die die über 60 sind würde
jetzt eben mehr impfstoff zur verfügung
stehen und impfen sei immer noch besser
als nicht impfen in den allermeisten
fällen so jetzt aber zu unserem fachmann
vom wie gesagt klinikum rechts der isar
drs ist verschwindet erstmal schönen
guten abend sie haben die
bundespressekonferenz bzw
so heißt es nicht aber die
pressekonferenz der kanzlerin und des
gesundheitsministers gerade auch
mitbekommen wie wird die ganze
institution das ganze geschehen rund um
astrazeneca auf sie als sozusagen an der
praxis der ja auch mit dem impfstoff zu
tun hat schönen guten abend ich glaube
was wir heute sehen konnten ist dass wir
uns wirklich darauf verlassen können
dass die sicherheitsüberwachung noch
zugelassene impfstoffe und arzneimittel
wirksam funktioniert selbst kleinste
sicherheits signale die vor nicht ganz
zwei wochen wahrgenommen wurden wurden
unmittelbar bewertet geprüft und das
ergebnis können wir heute sehen ich
glaube ist ein großer beweis dass sich
die menschen im land wirklich auf die
prüfmechanismen verlassen können dass
insgesamt etwas verwirrung und
unsicherheit entsteht mit den vielen
unterschiedlichen botschaften der
letzten wochen
man kommuniziert wurden kann ich zwar
gut nachvollziehen aber auf der anderen
seite kann ich jetzt als wissenschaftler
auch nur begrüßen dass maximal
transparent mit den ereignissen
umgegangen wird
kritik gibt es natürlich schon also
unter anderem von seiten der
patientenschützer ich zitiere mal gerade
hier herrenbrück eugen brysch
er ist dort eben funktionieren und ist
vorstand der stiftung patientenschutz
und er sagte erst sollten nur die unter
65-jährigen dann alle und jetzt nur die
über 60-jährigen den impfstoff bekommen
so entsteht der eindruck dass nicht alle
fakten auf den tisch gelegt werden ist
das ihrer meinung nach nachvollziehbar
eigentlich nicht denn die ursprüngliche
empfehlung genehm stoff zu den extras
bei älteren 1-sätzen lager daran dass in
der zulassungsstudie nur eine kleine
anzahl an menschen höheren lebensalters
eingeschlossen war der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat aber jetzt
noch einmal hervorgehoben dass
mittlerweile sehr viel mehr erfahrung
auch aus schottland vorliegt und es
deutliche hinweise darauf gibt dass das
dort weniger impfstoff insbesondere bei
älteren menschen besonders gut wirkt und
es gilt jetzt vor allem eine eher risiko
nutzen abwägung des nutzens des
impfstoffs dämmstoff sollen nämlich vor
allem schwere kost 19 verläuft
verhindern soll ja gerade ältere
menschen ihren besonders hohes risiko
haben wegen schwerer kost 19
erkrankungen in die klinik zu müssen und
im ungünstigsten fall vielleicht sogar
daran zu versterben wirksam schützen
die berichteten nebenwirkungen der
siemens venenthrombosen sind er trotz
allem sehr selten und nachts hypothese
also den möglichkeiten wie die zustande
kommen betreffen sie sehr wahrscheinlich
nur jüngere patientinnen und patienten
und deshalb finde ich die entscheidung
wie sie heute ist nachvollzogen wurde
der neben stoff vor allem weitere
menschen einzusetzen absolut
nachvollziehbar und ich glaube es bleibt
in dieser situation auch nur die
möglichkeit transparent mit den menschen
darüber zu kommunizieren was zur
entscheidungs änderungen geführt hat
denn ich glaube eines begegnete uns in
der coop 19 waren die häufig wir haben
sehr viel und sehr schnell dazugelernt
ein lernendes system der
bundesgesundheitsminister hat ja auch so
zu sagen versucht aus der not eine
tugend zu machen weil er sagt naja jetzt
stehen aber eben mehr impfdosen für
diejenigen die älter sind schon zur
verfügung die eigentlich für die
jüngeren vorgesehen waren würden sie das
ähnlich sehen
ich glaube das praktische handling
bietet sehr kompliziert wie man damit
dann in der praxis umgeht wir hatten ja
oft in der vergangenheit diskussionen
auch in der gesellschaft darüber wie
geimpft priorisierung eingehalten werden
kann und natürlich sollten die menschen
die das höchste risiko schwerer verläufe
und 19 bedingten todesfälle haben auch
aus meiner ärztlichen sicht bevorzugt
geschützt werden
auf der anderen seite müssen sie aber
auch vermeiden dass impfstoffdosen
ungenutzt verworfen werden also nicht
angewendet werden können weil es konkret
vor ort vielleicht nicht gelingt die im
freien folge ganze niebel umzusetzen
vielleicht und das war ja in den letzten
tagen und wochen auch immer wieder
diskussionsgegenstand sind ja auch gut
beraten etwas mehr flexibilität
zuzulassen dass die im freien folge zwar
insgesamt gewahrt bleibt aber ausnahmen
davon eben immer dann möglich sind wo
sie sinnvoll dazu beitragen dass wir
schnell viel mehr menschen impfen können
barbara berthold schreibt uns über
youtube ist doch besser dass man
reagiert als das man schweigt geht doch
nicht anders also auch sie sozusagen
findet es positiv dass man ebendort
erkenntnisse in die impfstrategie mit
einbezieht
vielleicht noch mal die frage auch an
sie weil sie eben auch so oft heute
abend gestellt wurde an uns was bedeutet
das nun jetzt für leute die unter 60
sind und die die erste impfung mit astra
schon hatten ist da sozusagen immer noch
zu empfehlen die zweite dann auch mit
astra sich geben zu lassen oder wie
welche einstellung haben sie dazu es war
ja bislang die empfehlungen zu sagen die
zweite impfung wird dann auch mit
astrazeneca entsprechend verabreicht
eigentlich nach etwa zwölf wochen
jetzt gibt es ja neue empfehlungen der
ständigen impfkommission die sich noch
mal sehr genau ansehen möchte doch ob
vielleicht in den nächsten tagen und
wochen schon erste ergebnisse der großen
studien
land dazu beitragen können wo die
kombination des astra zeneca impfstoffs
mit mrsa impfstoffen untersucht wird
also im kern geht es um die frage könnte
man den menschen die jetzt vielleicht
ein erhöhtes risiko dieser sehr seltenen
sinus venenthrombose kombination
komplikation haben also unter
60-jährigen menschen auch ein angebot
mit einem anderen impfstoff machen wir
wissen heute nicht ob das funktioniert
also ob diese kombination wirksam ist
wir wissen auch nicht ob diese
kombination sicher ist also vielleicht
unerwartete nebenwirkungen auftreten
deshalb kann man das so nicht empfehlen
und an dieser stelle natürlich bislang
immer die maßgabe die erste szene
kenterung fortzuführen jetzt mit dieser
neuen entscheidung lässt sich dieses so
nicht aufrechterhalten und das wird
jetzt vor allem darum gehen rasch eine
konkrete empfehlung zu machen die
schwierigkeit für uns wissenschaftlich
tätige ärzte liegt natürlich darin dass
wir empfehlungen nur auf der basis
verfügbarer studiendaten machen können
und diese sind hierfür im moment sehr
beschränkt deswegen was bleibt also
konkret zu empfehlen wer seine impfung
erst kürzlich erhalten hat würde die
nächste eben vom ersten zehn bis zwölf
wochen erhalten hier bleibt also noch
etwas zeit um zu überlegen wie weiter
konkret vorzugehen ist und ansonsten ist
eine individuelle risiko nutzen beratung
entsprechend erforderlich ob die zweite
impfung dann genau so fortgeführt werden
kann die die erste im grunde ist es
natürlich möglich will es noch einmal
hervorheben
die sehen dass wenn thrombosen die er
diskutiert werden und ja häufiger sind
als man sie erwartet hätte sind trotz
allem sehr seltene ehre krankheits
komplikationen
das heißt es gilt dem auch das
individuelle risiko einer schweren kopf
19 erkrankungen entgegenzusetzen
denn davor schützt der impfstoff genau
um gerade vielleicht auch noch mal hier
das bild unserer community abzuholen es
gibt also einige user die schreiben sie
soll der astra zeneca impfstoff damit
nun sozusagen endgültig diskreditiert
die wollen auf gar keinen fall aber es
gibt auch andere auffassungen christa
winkler zum beispiel schreibt über
facebook 2,8 millionen menschen weltweit
sind an oder mit cupid gestorben dagegen
steht jetzt eine einstellige zahl an
toten in deutschland leute kommt auch
mal wieder runter
dass also auch ein beitrag hier bei uns
und wir wollen uns gerade für die leute
die die pressekonferenz verpasst haben
wir sprechen gleich weiter noch einmal
die zentralen aussagen anhören der
bundeskanzlerin und auch des
bundesgesundheitsministers die
empfehlung der ständigen impfkommission
beruhen auf erkenntnissen die fachleute
in den vergangenen wochen über sehr
seltene gleichwohl sehr schwere fälle
von thrombosen bei mit astrazeneca
dümmsten personen gesammelt haben
es sind erkenntnisse die die ständige
impfkommission und damit schließlich
auch wir nicht ignorieren können
deshalb haben bund und länder heute
abend entschieden der empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission zu folgen
wir werden veränderungen an den leaf
ablehnen vornehmen müssen an der
verteilung auf impfzentren auf mobile
teams und gleich nach ostern auch auf
die hausärzte
das werden wir bund und länder und die
vielen engagierten kräfte in den
kommunen gemeinsam anpacken und
bewältigen
insgesamt geht es um ein abwägen
zwischen den risiken einer nebenwirkung
die statistisch gering aber ernst zu
nehmen ist und dem risiko an krone zu
erkranken und einen schweren verlauf
oder langzeit folgen der krankheit zu
erleiden und in dieser abwägung da sind
sich unsere expertinnen und experten
sehr einig gilt eines sehr klar impfen
ist fast immer die bessere entscheidung
soweit also nochmal die beiden
spitzenpolitiker
wir sprechen weiter mit christoph
spinner vom klinikum rechts der isar
oberarzt macht unter anderem auch einen
podcast mit den kollegen vom br zum
thema corona noch mal die frage rechnen
sie damit dass die menschen den
impfstoff jetzt vermehrt ablehnen werden
oder sehen sie die chance da trotzdem
noch die sozusagen akzeptanz am leben zu
erhalten
die verunsicherung insbesondere für den
astra weniger impfstoff hat er in den
letzten tagen und wochen noch mal
erheblich zugenommen nachdem es erste
berichte der sinus venenthrombosen gar
zuvor gab es die nicht ganz glückliche
kommunikation seiner wirksamkeit ich
kann gut verstehen dass menschen auch
verunsichert sind denn wir diskutieren
hier einen sehr komplexen zusammenhang
von klinischen studien und ihrer
bedeutung in der praxis ich denke die
freiwilligkeit der im
funk und die gute aufklärung also die
selbstbestimmte entscheidung jedes
patienten jeder patientin ist
entscheidend und ich persönlich finde es
sehr positiv dass wir transparent jetzt
mit den ereignissen umgegangen wird und
auch jeder mensch sich ein eigenes
urteil bilden kann jeder impfung geht ja
auch ein ärztliches aufklärungsgespräch
voran so dass eine individuelle risiko
nutzen abwägung möglich ist ganz
entscheidend ist aber und das sehen wir
auch in den letzten tagen und wochen das
astra zeneca impfstoff termine deutlich
weniger wahrgenommen werden als
impftermine mit anderen impfstoffen
jedenfalls dass die botschaft lich aus
einigen impfzentren wahrnehme glaube
heute ist durch die entscheidung
vielleicht auch ein grundstein gelegt
ein stück vertrauen zurückzugewinnen
nehmen für jeden wirklich transparent
ist das auch negative ereignisse auch
negative ereignisse die der
sicherheitsprofil von impfstoffen
beeinflussen klar und öffentlich
kommuniziert werden und trotz allem
entsprechen wir bei der sinus
venenthrombose ja von sehr seltenen
ereignissen
ich bin mir also sicher wenn die
freiwilligkeit des astra zeneca
impfstoffs erhalten bleibt gibt es viele
menschen die sich dennoch impfen lassen
und es macht aus meiner sicht nach
absolut sinn
wir sprechen von nicht ganz 30
ereignissen auf etwa 1,8 millionen für
impfdosen gleichzeitig steigen die kurve
19 infektionszahlen wir sehen zunehmende
patientinnen zahlen in den kliniken also
ich glaube gerade jetzt kommt es darauf
an dass wir jedem stoß ist nutzen die
uns zur verfügung steht ja da also auch
noch mal der hinweis auf die relation
eben das verhältnis der zahlen mit
sicherheit auch berechtigt die frage die
ich mir noch gestellt habe einige
kliniken haben ja heute ihre impfungen
der mitarbeiterinnen unter 60 oder unter
55 je nachdem mit astrazeneca gestoppt
wie halten sie das bei ihnen am haus und
ihrem klinikum er für uns stellt sich
diese frage nicht weil er seinen anfang
an nur biontech weißer impfstoff impfen
verschiedene logistische gründe
aber ich glaube die entscheidung die
jetzt die kliniken hier getroffen hatten
heute im vorgriff auf die
diese empfehlung des im programm für die
unter 60-jährigen entsprechend
vorübergehend auszusetzen ist ja
nachvollziehbar und auch hier wird jetzt
das prinzip der freiwilligkeit greifen
es wird auch unter den mitarbeitern den
weiterhin menschen geben die auch aus
meiner sicht absolut zurecht bereit sind
sich weiter mit astrazeneca impfen zu
lassen
andere werden vielleicht auch andere
impfstoffe warten wollen in kürze wird
er auch bei johnson & johnson eben stoff
wer bereits zugelassen ist zur verfügung
stehen und dass gesundheitsministerin
die bundeskanzlerin hatte neben
angekündigt in den nächsten tagen und
wochen kann mit einem erheblich größeren
menge an verfügbaren impfstoffen
gerechnet werden und ich glaube dass
auch eine meiner persönlichen haupt
botschaften es kommt jetzt darauf an
dass ich möglichst viele menschen leben
lassen damit wir die bande mehr zum
vorzeitigen stillstand bringen
sie sprachen gerade den impfstoff von
johnson & johnson an weil das auch eine
frage bei uns im netzwerk bahn rechnen
sie mit dem es gibt die ankündigungen
des pharmazeutischen unternehmers dass
er ab dem 10
april zur verfügung stehen soll und ich
glaube dieser impfstoff ist wichtig vor
allem für die einfachheit der impfung
denn er muss nur einmalig verimpft
werden kann bei kühlschranktemperatur
gelagert werden also ein impfstoff der
sich ideal auch für die dezentrale
impfung ausserhalb der grossen
impfzentren eignet denn auch wenn die
lager und transport bedingungen für den
engeren hemmstoff von beyoncé kreis hat
in deutschland eine große rolle spielt
vereinfacht wurden es dass dennoch
eigentlich nur in großen zentren
sinnvoll diesen impfstoff mit der
logistik tiefgefroren entsprechend
aufzutauen und die fertig für die
verschiffung vorzubereiten
letzte frage weil es eben heute zentral
um den impfstoff von astrazeneca gegen
noch mal ganz konkret von ihnen würden
sie weiterempfehlen und zwar aus allen
teilen der bevölkerung sich weiter damit
impfen zu lassen
grundsätzlich hat der astra weniger
impfstoff aus meiner sicht weiterhin ein
günstiges nutzen-risiko-verhältnis dh
seine schutzwirkung ist sehr viel höher
als die möglichen erwartungen
komplikationen
aber ich glaube man muss patientinnen
und patienten natürlich zu recht auch
das risiko des sinus wählen thrombose
auch wenn es wirklich sehr selten aber
die größenordnung etwas mehr als 30
fälle pro 1,6 1,8 millionen dosen ist
dass dieses risiko muss man im
individuellen arzt patienten gespräch
besprechen und natürlich sollte sich
jeder nur daneben können lassen wenn er
dies auch mit einem guten gefühl gefühl
tun kann
auf der anderen seite ist es auch
wichtig auf das risiko und die symptome
der sinus venenthrombose entsprechend
aufzuklären auch das war gegenstand der
diskussion aber ganz grundsätzlich würde
ich den 18 km stock unverändert entgegen
das schlusswort und die einschätzung von
dr christoph spinner klinikum rechts der
isar in münchen oberarzt für innere
medizin und infektiologie vielen dank
dass sie sich die zeit für uns heute
abend genommen haben einen schönen gruß
nach münchen
ja und das war unser live stream zum
thema astrazeneca und dem weiteren
umgang mit diesem impfstoff wir danken
für euer interesse den euro zahlreichen
zuschriften und wünschen euch noch einen
schönen abends bis demnächst